i do have the most amazing wonderful
perfect most beautiful girlfriend in the
whole world
it's not something i'm ashamed of i just
haven't shown the internet yet
that was jojo siwa last week gushing
over her girlfriend on the tonight show
and now she's revealing who the lucky
lady is
i feel awesome like it's so epic just to
think that like this is my life
on monday the 17 year old entertainer
took to instagram to introduce her
girlfriend
kylie jojo posted a series of photos of
them together
rocking cute onesies hanging out at
amusement parks and having a blast
together
she also shared a video of the two
singing along to justin bieber's as long
as you love
me
[Music]
the nickelodeon star shared in the
caption that she and kylie have been
best friends for over a year
and that she's the happiest she's ever
been since they made it official
one month ago jojo gushed quote
she seriously is the most loving
supportive happiest
protective and just the most beautiful
perfect person in the world
and i get to call her mine
[Music]
jojo who came out as a member of the
lgbt community last month
appeared in this tick tock video which
included the hashtag
pridehousela and the caption now you're
one of us
the social media star followed the video
days later with a photo wearing a shirt
that says
best gay cousin ever she thanked fans
for their support during an instagram
live
i have gotten the most endless amount of
love
and support and it is hmm
but i right now what matters is that
you guys know that no matter who you
love
that it's okay and that it's awesome and
that the world is there for you there's
so many people
that are there for you during jojo's
appearance on the tonight show she
opened up to host jimmy fallon about how
kylie inspired and supported her
decision to come
out about 10 minutes before i came out
to do this interview today
i was again on the phone with with my
girl
and i started crying and she's like
what's wrong with you
and i was like i'm just so happy i was
like because now i get to share
what makes me the happiest with the
world and it makes
my heart so happy jojo says that while
she knew coming out was a risk
it was all worth it in the end i was
like well technically
that was a really big risk that i took
posting that but i was like
but honestly and she was like why
because you could have lost everything
and i was like yeah
but if i lost everything that i've
created
because of being myself and because of
loving who i want to love
i don't want it that's not that that's
not what i want if i can't
if i can't love who i want to love
that's one of the most important things
to me